public sénat en partenariat avec
l'afrique
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gérard larcher le président du sénat est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir
soi et merci beaucoup d'être avec nous à
cinq jours du second tour des
législatives alors bien sûr on nous
annonce un parlement macron vous
répondrais ce soir à jean francis
pécresse des échos et de radio classique
à nadège peljak de l' agence
france-presse et de michaël szames s de
public sénat trois grandes questions
vous seront posées ce soir gérard
larcher d'abord est ce la fin de
l'opposition ensuite est ce que vous
prenez une attitude constructive enfin
une votre party les républicains est il
un parti en sursis mais d'abord une
toute première question d'actualité
[Musique]
il ya bien sûr des voix à droite qui
appelle au sursaut gérard larcher mais
franchement c'est plié en tous les cas
dimanche
la france va donner au président de la
république une large majorité
c'est d'ailleurs une logique des
institutions n'a souvent dit que depuis
la réforme du quinquennat
c'était la réplique sismique de
l'élection présidentielle disons sur
l'échelle de richter
c'est une réplique est forte oui mais la
démocratie c'est aussi à côté d'une
majorité stable et clair une opposition
responsable qui propose une opposition
qui parfois doit aussi au delà du
contrôle s'opposer à qui doit on rester
d'abord est ce que vous pensez possible
rééquilibrage décidé dimanche je pense
que ce rééquilibrage c'est ça la notion
du sursaut est nécessaire y compris pour
la réussite du cac et da d'emmanuel
macron commentaire parce que pour ça le
dire je compare souvent ça à la claude
baz qui font un fronton parfois pour
renvoyer les balles et pour construire
dans le pays il faut toujours que le
débat ait lieu au parlement sinon ça se
termine dans la rue et c'était une des
inquiétudes que j'avais exprimé chez un
de vos confrères la semaine dernière
alors dans le parisien 1
mais alors je ne comprends pas quels
sont vos arguments alors
pour va essayer d'obtenir ce
rééquilibrage alors qu'on entend sur le
terrain des candidats et leurs équipes
qui défendent emmanuel macron près de 52
% de nos compatriotes
les électeurs n'ont pas voté et c'est
quand même un vrai sujet attention à la
tentation du parti unique la première
victime
ce serait la participation citoyenne
comme si tout était réglé et je dois
dire que il est important que celles et
ceux qui sont attentifs au
fonctionnement de la démocratie ne se
disent pas c'est plié
c'est réglé il faut que dimanche ils
aillent voter quelle que soit leur vote
je crois que la première réponse et doit
être une réponse de citoyens alors vous
nous dites à une en fait un sursaut
politique mais également un sursaut
citoyen oui indispensable parce que vous
savez aujourd'hui près d'eux si on prend
le chiffre 23 % des français avait
choisi emmanuel macron va y avoir 80 %
de députées chez les chiffres qu'on
annonce oui est ce qu'il n'ya pas une
petite discordances dans tout ça alors
vous connaissez bien sûr parfaitement la
carte électorale nationale
j'ai arraché alors on va prendre
l'exemple des yvelines le département où
vous êtes et les résultats très
médiocres c'est incroyable et il n'y
aurait sans doute il pourrait n'y avoir
aucun député de droite pour règlement
auquel que vous avez jamais dans mon
pire cauchemar imaginez un tel décor
série a même cauchemar
non je regarde la réalité en face nous
voyons des des candidats qui n'étaient
inconnu sur le terrain en fait ils sont
des hologrammes d' emmanuel macron c'est
ça qui a déterminé de l'élection c'est
aussi parce que notre pays a une telle
angoisse telle situation de désarroi le
désir qu'on travaille ensemble qui sont
allés vers ce ce choix et beaucoup de
nos candidats sont vraiment ces zones
europe des macros je le dis avec respect
bon les candidats et pour emmanuel
macron oui vous ne vous dites quand même
à propos d' emmanuel macron produite
quand même chapeau l'artiste
parce qu'alors franchement en un peu
plus de 12 mois regarder ce qu'il a
réalisé un an
sans faute il a réussi parfaitement
c'est des aviations de désagréments des
pays dans un quinquennat qui avait été
l'échec absolu un président de la
république qui a réussi à tuer quasiment
totalement son parti politique d'achat
pour l'artiste je dis chapeau politique
chapeau le politique il faut se souvenir
qu'il ya six mois en annoncé 400 450
députés de droite a détruit en tous les
cas ce que vous me posiez comme question
à la fin de l'année voilà on voit bien
qu'en démocratie rien n'est jamais
acquis avant le choix des électeurs
alors la suite de l'épreuve de vérité
tout de suite avec michaël szames s2
public sénat qui vient vous poser sa
question
[Musique]
bonsoir michael bon sens michel bon sens
monsieur larcher bonsoir donc jamais
compris avec eux ce que vous m'aidiez
avec avec michel conscient avec la vague
qui se prépare à déferler sur
l'assemblée nationale vous diriez qu'il
n'y a plus d'opposition
d'abord je souhaite dire aux français
qui nous écoutent qu'il faut qu'il y ait
une opposition
c'est indispensable pour la démocratie
la démocratie c'est comme un coeur des
deux ventricules ou deux piliers les
piliers chanteur un qui fait c'est le
rôle de la majorité qui conduit une
politique qui soutient un gouvernement
et un autre pilier qui s'assure qu'ils
proposent qui peut d'ailleurs co
construire à certains moments mais qui
est la garantie de l'expression de
doutes d'interrogations et qui est une
exigence signe presque plus ou plus
d'opposition vous avez dit de ne pas les
du risque de la rue est ce qu'il ya un
risque pour la démocratie comme le dit
notamment pierre laurent patron du parti
communiste le risque de la rue c'est
naturellement le risque pour la
démocratie
je préfère que ce soit au parlement ce
débat voilà pourquoi à l'assemblée
nationale il est important chaque député
d'opposition en plus par rapport aux
projections
ce sera un peu plus de démocratie
vivante
c'est un point important président la
république est sûr d'avoir cette
majorité claire et stable
en plus il se dit
les nouveaux députés marcherait en fils
c'est à dire ça c'est à dire banale
croire prison d reçu une lettre disant
qu'ils aient choqué mais aucun mandat
des impératifs et vous savez je vous
espérez que l'esprit de liberté
l'emportera surtout ici au sénat on sait
bien vous serez d'esprit digne
l'assemblée nationale et je crois
vraiment qui a une responsabilité des
citoyens et chaque député d'opposition
qui peut être en même temps un homme
positif
une femme positive c'est un peu plus
démocrate et godillots de parler déjà à
l'époque de la droite il y aurait rien
de nouveau dans sa grille un nouveau on
l'a connu en 1993
ce n'est pas terriblement bien ternes à
l'époque où vous ne seriez pas inquiété
d'une sorte d j'ai mené au d'absolutisme
politique quand c'était la droite qui
ont bénéficié de sa campagne
je vous rappelle nous étions dans le
septennat et aujourd'hui on est dans la
réplique sismique de l'élection
présidentielle c'est d'ailleurs un un
vrai sujet par rapport à la réforme du
quinquennat
moi qui suis pour le scrutin majoritaire
en même temps je sais que nous aurons un
débat sur une place de proportionnelle
vous en pensez quoi de nous vivons au
sénat la proportionnelle puisque presque
du deux tiers des sénateurs presque 75%
de mains des sénateurs seront élus à la
proportionnelle
je reste très attaché au scrutin
majoritaire qu'est la relation entre un
homme une femme et un territoire
donc les citoyens j'avais fait
territoire on courait le débat sur une
part de proportionnelle n'ai pas peur
parce qu'il doit philippe ne sait pas
mesurer encore là la hauteur de ce sera
entre 10 et 20% et ne faut pas non plus
que ce soit un facteur d'instabilité et
la réforme du quinquennat et en train
des mots démontrer ce que nous répétions
à quelques-uns attention la réplique
alors oui ça veut dire ça veut dire si
on vous entend bien aujourd'hui que vous
seriez prêt s'il ya texte arrivait
est-ce qu'il faut une réforme
constitutionnelle pour nom il faut une
simple loi selon qu'on a vécu avec
françois mitterrand donc vous soyez là
black et sécurité c'est de la question
qui peut être posée au conseil
est-ce qu'on fait cohabiter un scrutin
majoritaire
une part du scrutin proportionnel
l'exemple du sénat le montrer une partie
de nos collègues sont élus au scrutin
majoritaire
une partie dont je suis et est élu au
scrutin pourquoi alors vous à vous
utilisez beaucoup l'expression répliques
sismiques
1 est-ce qu'il faut l'empêcher en
revenant sur le calendrier électoral qui
place les législatives après la
présidentielle est ce qu'il faut revenir
l'a vendu le sujet si le cac et n'a pas
été tranchée c'est déjà ça a été un
débat et quand on gagne pas on remet pas
en cause toutes les règles du jeu quand
on ne gagne pas on se pose la question
sur soi même pourquoi nous en sommes là
et en même temps qu'est ce qu'attendent
les français c'est le rôle des
formations politiques c'est le rôle des
groupes politiques et on n'a pas parlé
du sénat jusque là avant jane mais est
ce le sénat va jouer un rôle important
car c'est assez juste votre quel rôle
pour le cédrat après que peut-être on
verra bien dimanche mais au moins 400
députés des de la république en marche
et weya près de 3 inexpérimenté ans j'ai
présenté ma candidature ici j'avais un
thème d'opposition constructive
lorsqu'à un mot qu'on répète beaucoup à
l'époque il était moins usité c'était un
choix que j'avais fait par rapport à
d'autres parce que je pense que le pays
attend de notre part
même si nous avons des idées différents
qu'on se préoccupe d'abord de lui et
quand je disais toujours le pays c'est
beaucoup plus important que mon parti
moi qui me suis engagé extrêmement tôt
dans ma formation politique qui ont
suivi membres et donc je vis ça
profondément je dois dire et le sénat
demain ça va être un espace de vraie
liberté à l'endroit que l'assemblée
avoir de l'exigence des propositions où
on n'est pas dans le dogmatisme et je
dois dire c'est ce que voulait dire si
je me demande tout à fait pour ça mais
on le sait les maires de l'assemblée
d'or est-ce que l'assemblée puisque
c'est pas un mot facile godillots
peut-être eux
moi je suis confiance aux collègues de
l'assemblée nationale se fait mais ici
il ya un espace de liberté
il ya un espace d'initiative c'est vrai
que nous ne sommes jamais aligné nous ne
sommes jamais en fils
souvenez-vous du quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy
la majorité ici était majoritairement
dans la majorité présidentielle de
l'époque et pourtant sur nombre de
sujets là exprimé sa liberté tant que
vous entendez que le sénat exprime
encore plus sa singularité la majorité
sénatoriale n'est pas automatiquement
calquée sur la majorité présidentielle
c'est un point important de même que
l'opposition au sénat s'appelle souvent
groupes minoritaires plutôt groupe
d'opposition et moi je suis très
attentif aux droits de l'opposition
sadate d'ailleurs à ce sujet à
l'assemblée nationale puisque nous
aurons des groupes d'opposition à gauche
comme au centre et à droite qui seront
on le sait beaucoup plus réduit qu'on ne
l'imaginait les droits de l'opposition
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel vous
vous demandez aujourd'hui est-ce que ce
droit d'opposition soient les majeures
futur le poids la première de jonathan
menace est que j'appelle mes
compatriotes à donner à l'opposition
suffisamment de force et en même temps
je me dis que les droits de l'opposition
vont être encore plus sacré dans une
assemblée qui naturellement va sur
représentés je rappelle que 31 ans et
demi pour cent ça fait 80 % de députées
c'est la cinquième république ça ne me
choque pas mais en même temps les droits
de l'opposition
c'est un sujet essentiel on prête l'idée
au chef de l'état contesté paraît-il en
interne chez les maquereaux nist de
désigner un président de faire désigner
de faire élire un président de
l'assemblée nationale de la droite est
ce que vous pensez que ce serait une
bonne idée dans ce qu'elle fait dans le
cadre des outils qui vivent ça ne me
plairait c'est là qu'ils se décideront
les députés je ne leur demande pas de se
mêler des choix au sénat
c'est le député guy lution ce sera le
choix du gouvernement
mais au bout du compte si c'est la même
tradition plus et n'a peut-être un peu
différent chez les députés notamment des
députés nouveau c'est eux et eux seuls
qui maximum que vous avez mesuré
l'impact de la république en marche sur
les futures élections sénatoriales
non mais ça peut avoir un impact
le vrai sujet c'est que notre corps
électoral en dehors d'avoir été
essentiellement constituée dans des
élections municipales puis les élections
départementales et régionales est
particulièrement attentif au sujet du
territoire et jusque là on n'a pas
beaucoup entendu il président de la
république ni le premier ministre sur le
sujet du territoire le rôle et la place
de la commune des intercommunalités
dans le cas d'un one shot la réforme de
la taxe d'habitation les réformes des
dotations
quelle vision de la poursuite ou non de
la décentralisation
les premiers signaux qu'on a reçues sont
plutôt des signaux de recentralisation
ces débrayages à quoi trois semaines à
moi oui vous savez au président de la
république je disais au président de la
république en le recevant il a eu la
courtoisie de venir me voir
la veille de son investiture et nous
avons eu un échange nous étions tous les
deux
et dans cet échange velits monsieur le
président vous êtes le président d'un
pays fracturée et d'appeler fracturé en
plus géographiquement et
territorialement et que le rôle du sénat
c'est d'essayer de contribuer à recoudre
ce territoire il n'y a pas qu'une france
de métropole et de quelques régions
puissante
il ya une france qui est tout à la fois
et je crois que une partie des votes
extrêmes
c'est le sentiment presque d'une
majorité de nos concitoyens de ne plus
être dans le jeu aujourd'hui de ne plus
être considéré de plus être pris en
cours est ce qu'on peut vous demander
quelle a été sa réponse qui n'y serai
très attentif et que nous c'est un débat
que nous allons poursuivre donc voulais
le revoir la liste la semaine prochaine
et nous nous rencontrerons très bientôt
avec le président de la république
vous savez moi c'est ma manière vous
faire et à la chaîne vous n'avez peu ou
pas dit ce que vous serez candidat 11
septembre à nouveau l'ag réjouis du
sénat vous du jeudi c'est il ya une
majorité soit parce que je poursuive
dans le cadre de la majorité sénatoriale
actuelle je poursuivrai
chez les sénateurs qui décideront comme
je le souhaite les députés décideront
alors sur leur futur président sur autre
chose peut-être on assiste aujourd'hui
une passe d'armes entre le premier
ministre et françois bayrou le ministre
de la justice
le garde des sceaux l'a rappelé à son
devoir d'exemplarité notamment par
rapport à une question sur les médias
françois bayrou lui a rétorqué en
quelque sorte c'est un peu ce que je
veux c'est c'est drôle d'ambiance quand
même coûté j'ai pas d'abord le principe
c'est que la presse est libre et le
1005ha je dis bien non il y eu la
ministre du travail a fait qu'il n'est
pas contre un média mais sur l'attitude
éventuelle de fonctionnaires du
ministère du travail alors en précisant
qu'il y avait dévié délai la fuite d'un
document qui a été publiée par
libération un document préparatoire à la
loi travail donc elle le ministère a
décidé de porter plainte
il a raison c'est le respect du droit à
fonctionner redoux et royal mais
s'épanouit pas une pression contre les
médias on est ce que demandait la
loyauté un fonctionnaire était les frais
paillot certaine conception du service
de l'état et nous sommes en attente un
certain niveau du service de l'état se
prépare les fonctionnels hefner radio
france quand on est mis les injustices
après un autre sujet mais c'est
tellement totalement différent il ya un
problème de cohérence surtout pour un
garde des sceaux à intervenir auprès du
directeur d'un média c'est vrai que
comprendre l'énervement on connaît je
peux vous dire que quand on est dans
cette fonction c'est quelque chose qu'on
connaît compris le président du sénat
mais quand on est ministre quand on est
président d'une institution
on a des devoir je comprends la réaction
du premier ministre donc vous approuvez
le recadrage edouard philippe
aujourd'hui de départ promettait ça je
le comprends et je ferais la même chose
ainsi eux de se passer quelques années
d'équivalent dans mon institut chaleur
mais pendant que moi de poser peut-être
mais la question sur cette question 3 0
ça ressemble quand même drôle de caillou
dans la chaussure des manuels macro non
je sais pas en tous les cas c'est un
caillou blanc qui l'a emporté avec lui
qu'il a peut-être des attributs ils ont
décidé de travailler ensemble
et bien il faut qu'il travaille ensemble
est ce que vous estimez qu'il est
qualifié pour porter la loi de
moralisation
i politique puisque le canard enchaîné
ce soir publie des témoignages d'anciens
assistant parlementaire européen du
modem qui contredisent un peu la version
initiale suite enquête préliminaire a
été ouverte alors toujours refusé à
commenter notamment les enquêtes
préliminaires
ils sont les choses se faire le ministre
d'état françois bayrou est venu me voir
pour parler du texte confiance des orane
auquel je tenais plutôt que mot
moralisation
comme si la vie publique était par
nature à moral ou immoral
par contre je partage vous le savez le
désir que on retrouve la confiance entre
les citoyens les parlementaires je ne
cesse de dire qu'il ne suffit pas que
les mères il maire-adjoint les
conseillers municipaux et la confiance
des français
ils sont les seuls donc retrouver la
confiance est une démarche je n'en doute
pas que sénat accompagnera et depuis
d'ailleurs début 2015
le sénat a fait beaucoup de pas dans
cette direction vous serez constructif
sur ce sujet c'est la gâteau positif
positive beau score à trois ans j'étais
constructif
on va utiliser le mot lancé on va encore
quand même utiliser ce mot dans la
question qui vient merci beaucoup
michael mai 2008
c'est jean francis pécresse le directeur
de la rédaction de radio classique qui
nous rejoint
[Musique]
jean michel bonsoir au soir larcher
alors il y a des bâches et les
républicains sur la nature de
l'opposition à emmanuel macron et à
cette majorité cette majorité massive de
la république en marche débat entre nos
positions constructives et une position
plus obstructive est ce que vous serez
en tant que président du sénat partisan
d'une opposition constructive d'une
position et je crois que je me suis déjà
on va l'expliquer en répondant aux
questions de votre confrère c'est depuis
trois ans la tique et que nous avons je
rappelle quand même que nous avons voté
près de 75% des textes après amendement
des gouvernements de manuel valls et
jean que c'est ici de l'adn de la maison
est-ce qu'on est constructif pour être
constructif non ce qui compte c'est et
c'est d'ailleurs la tombe de nos
concitoyens en sorte notre pays des
grandes difficultés qu'il connaît en
matière d'emploi
en matière de dépenses publiques en
matière de déficit
c'est sale attente de nos concitoyens
alors est ce que mon attitude et
constructive au obstructive sur armand
obstructif sauf quand on touche aux
libertés fondamentales
c'est un point sur lequel on ne transige
pas souvenez vous de la réforme
constitutionnelle voulue par françois
hollande de la déchéance de nationalité
et de mes propos sur ce plateau sur le
passeport nansen sur l'apatridie
quand on dit non ici on dit rarement
espèce est un nom absolue est ce que ça
veut dire que vous vous opposeriez à
l'intégration des dispositifs des
dispositions de l'état d'urgence dans la
loi ordinaire
d'abord nous allons débattre au mois de
juillet de la reconduction jusqu'à
l'automne et de l'état d'urgence dans le
cadre mais il y à un débat qui n'est pas
médiocre qui a déjà été ici entamé
largement par le président de la
commission des lois
philippe bas et par michel mercier donc
le rapporteur et sur les sujets par
exemple
du de la rétention administrative sur le
suivi de sujet du suivi de personnalité
entre guillemets personnalité plutôt de
personnes fichées ou particulièrement
suivie il ya un sujet sur par exemple
les perquisitions
tous ces sujets là on sera attentif aux
libertés vigilant on sera vigilant parce
que la limite ici c'est la protection
des libertés individuelles et
collectives
mais en même temps on ne méconnaît pas
la réalité du terrorisme bien ce que
l'insécurité il ya encore une fuite
peut-être dans la presse c'est parce que
vous en pensez mais là on avoue
également la semaine dernière dans le
monde un avant texte inquiets par
exemple donner le pouvoir à la justice
administrative
est-ce que cela ça vous inquiète t elle
à ce que vous pourriez faire blocage
c'est sans doute sur ces sujets là que
nous serons particulièrement attentifs
c'est un point sur lequel nous étions
déjà attentif y est bien longtemps et je
pense que cette maison qui a mis en
place je le rappelle la commission
informatique et libertés le mot liberté
est un mot qui est créé sur le fronton
du sénat mais concrètement alors ouais
enfin où hélas la ligne à ne pas
franchir
elle est où cette ligne en de cette
ligne à ne pas franchir
parce que c'est exposition de l'état
d'urgence actuelle elle ne vous choque
pas non mais je rappelle que c'est une
disposition exceptionnelle pour un temps
donné les six ans sous le contrôle sous
le contrôle des juges deux commissions
de l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
si un certain nombre de procédures
deviennent des procédures ordinaires
il faut s'assurer que les libertés
individuelles et collectives soient
assurés d'ornon suis donc on ne sort pas
automatiquement de
l'état d'urgence en transférant tout ça
dans la loi ordinaire c'est ce que vous
nous dites pas leur engouement
alors oubliez parler sans doute français
de la loi travail de à écouter tout de
suite gens pensent que nous disait jean
france à couper ici même la semaine
dernière très enthousiaste il se trouve
que ce projet est exactement celui que
je défends aussi bien d'ailleurs sur le
fond que sur la méthode celle des
ordonnances ça fait des années que je le
préconise
parfois d'ailleurs contre l'avis de
nicolas sarkozy françois fillon une
certaine époque qui préférait de faire
des référendums
alors que je suis totalement partisan de
l'idée de faire cela par ordonnance tout
de suite profitant la dynamique
électorale
il faut vraiment que l'on puisse gagner
cette bataille là voyez je dit on parce
que sur ces sujets nous faisons front
commun avec emmanuel macron il ya
d'autres sujets de divergence mais sur
celui là évidemment qu'il faut le faire
pour la méthode d'abord est ce que la
méthode des ordonnances vous êtes frappé
par oui jésus avait même préparé pour
nos candidats auto trader alors ça ne
pose aucun problème problème alors je le
dis comme président du sénat les
ordonnances
oui à condition mon poids en abuser
ordonnance oui mais le débat doit aller
dans le cadre d'une ordonnance au fond
que ce soit un moment de l'habilitation
qu'au moment de la ratification le débat
il doit aussi d'un débat en commission
qui permet d'entendre sur le sujet
travail-emploi l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux
ça n'est pas un espèce de débat cash et
subreptice conclu on prêtait qu'il
faudrait aller vite c'est ce que disent
les syndicats tien passé j'étais encore
aujourd'hui oui enfin de ces deux
dialogue social en tous les cas moi
personnellement j'avais entamé avec eux
au mois de décembre
ce dialogue sur des sujets qu'on doit
retrouver dans les ordonnances qui est
le sujet du rôle de la place et du
niveau de l'accord d'entreprise et de
branches on va en parler justement
est-ce qu'on peut encore étendre au delà
de ce qui s'est fait avec la loi elle
comrie ce qui relève de l'accord
d'entreprise
aujourd'hui ce qui relève de ce type
d'accord c'est tout ce qui est relatif à
l'organisation du travail en général
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait mettre de plus
parce que le medef dit il faut encore et
en mai
mais concrètement qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait mettre de plus avant les
accords d'entreprise d'abord vous parlez
de la loi travail elle qu aubry dans sa
dernière version psychodrame 49 3 mais
pas du texte initial de la loi travail
et pas du texte qui était le fondement
c'est tout un travail qui était le
rapport de jean denis combrexelle oui
est ce qu'on donne à l'accord
d'entreprise
oui la capacité en quelque sorte à
déroger à ce qu'on a appelé la
hiérarchie des normes
je réponds oui sur un certain nombre de
sujets et que par exemple le sujet de la
nature du contrat dans l'entreprise je
pense aux contrats de mission peut être
un sujet débattu dans le cadre de
l'accord d'entreprise
je suis sur un poil attendait parce que
ça c'est quand même important parce que
ça veut dire que vous êtes favorable
vous est ce que ces accords s'impose au
contrat de travail c'est à dire que l'on
puisse les opposer de manière bien
jusqu'aux contrats très d'accord dans le
cadre elle que dans le cadre général aux
ados la protection défensif du droit du
travail
d'accord mais c'est ça la flexisécurité
adapté à l'entreprise accord je suis
aussi attaché c'est un point j'ai
rencontré la ministre du travail
la semaine passée à la dimension de
l'accord de branche que tu t'es un peu
oublié ces temps ci parce que l'accord
de branche
il est particulièrement adapté notamment
aux petites et moyennes entreprises et
55% de l'emploi dans ce pays c'est les
petites et moyennes entreprises
il faut donc que comme qu'on se dise une
fois pour toutes que la petite et
moyenne entreprise a besoin d'un droit
du travail qui s'adapte à sa réalité sur
la pénibilité la cgt aujourd'hui
10 après avoir vu les responsables du
ministère de l'emploi de travail dit que
le gouvernement aurait l'intention de
ramener ça à l'accord d'entreprise
précisément et de le retirer de l'accord
de branche en fin de la loi
essentiellement mais de l'accord de
branche pour ses déclinaisons pour les
référentiels côté je vais m'en tenir à
ce que j'ai échangé suspension d'un
compte qui fonctionne pas qui ne peut
pas fonctionner mais en même temps
est-ce que pour autant ça fait
disparaître la réalité de la pénibilité
je crois qu'il faut renvoyer à la
négociation cette dimension de la
pénibilité à la négociation
d'abord dans le cas du dialogue social
mais alors le divin d'une loi m né oui
important l'ensemble des partenaires
sociaux au niveau national aucune
négociation interprofessionnelle mais
enrichir mais elle a eu déjà 7 novembre
elle peut être très ouverte puisque ça
n'a pas fonctionné puisque ça n'a pas
fonctionné
elle doit même est très ouverte dans le
cadre d'une loi que je connais assez
bien le voit deux manuels de 2005 voilà
je pense que le gouvernement pratiquera
de cette manière en tous les cas je le
souhaite car ça ne peut pas la question
de la pénibilité
elle peut être adapté dans l'accord
d'entreprise il ya quelques principes
fondamentaux qu'il faut définir dans le
cadre d'un accord national ou en tous
les cas dans le cadre d'un dialogue
national qui s'il n'y a pas d'accord
sera tranchée par le parlement en tous
les cas vous avez rencontré la ministre
du travail à quelques jours vous l'avez
dit vous êtes sur la même longueur
d'onde quoi pas sur tous les sujets le
globe alain évidemment mais je connais
bien la menace du travail puisque quand
j'étais menée du travail je lui avais
proposé l'été devenus des président de
l'institut du travail
il dira que je pensais que c'était une
femme qui connaissait bien ses sujets là
il ya d'autres sujets dans les
ordonnances qui sont des sujets
particulièrement importants
la question de la sécurisation de l'
embauche et notamment la question des
indemnités devant les prud'hommes
c'est un élément de sécurisation moi
j'aurais souhaité qu'on y met aussi les
seuls
et je n'ai dit à la ministre car les
seuils passé de 10 à 20 les seuils
sociaux c'est-à-dire les seuls vrais de
dons d'envoi l'adsl sa créance à sas a
créé d'emplois d'accord et notre sujet
aujourd'hui vous avez que samsung
chiffres sur un peu meilleur des 30
jours vous avez le sentiment d'être
entendu écouté ce sera le rôle du débat
parlementaire
ouais d'accord on va parler de la
moralisation de la vie publique dont le
projet la confiance donc de la confiance
dans le dos les projets de loi ou le
projet de loi arrive en conseil demain
mais avant je voulais savoir il ya débat
encore il ya un autre débat il y en a
beaucoup en ce moment au sein des
républicains sur le sud sur la question
de savoir si il faut voter la confiance
au premier ministre edouard philippe ou
pas d'abord je voulais savoir si l'eau
si le gouvernement demande au sénat un
vote de confiance est ce que vous êtes
enclin à la voter cette confiance
aujourd'hui d'abord il salue pas une
obligation le seul à lui seul la
différence pour ça que je dis de
l'assemblée nationale
c'est à des sujets dont nous parlerons
avec le premier ministre la semaine
prochaine s'il souhaite ou non demander
la confiance aussi au sénat vous savez
pour voter la confiance faut connaître
le texte vous connaître sur quoi la
confiance est appelée de quelle manière
elle est appelée la confiance c'est pas
non plus une espèce de prison derrière
laquelle on s'enferme c'est pas un
blanc-seing qui est donné donc il y aura
un débat à l'intérieur des groupes et
c'est à l'issue du débat à l'intérieur
des groupes que sera décidé ou non de
voter cette confiance on ne regarde
jamais les choses a priori ici au sénat
donc elle n'est pas automatique m elle
ne va pas de soi le vote de confiance de
la part naturelle ne va pas de soi la
confiance et je crois que la confiance
elle se construit elle se construit par
les propositions et il appartiendra au
premier ministre de faire des
propositions
il viendra devant le sénat pour nous
faire part de ses propositions afin que
vos amis le 5 juillet
prochain c'est tout moi la date que nous
avons près retenue et donc nous
écouterons et nous verrons si nous
partageons thaler certains vos amis ont
une position anticipé parce qu'ils
annoncent déjà qu'ils voteraient la
confiance entre alors à leur toute
dernière question il nous reste moins
d'une minute alors sur la confiance dans
la vie publique il ya vous avez fait une
proposition intéressante qui essaie elle
une chaude entre autres une seule qui
est celle de supprimer la réserve
ministérielle puisque vous nous avez
appris à beaucoup que il y avait la
réserve parlementaire qui allaient être
enlevées mais qu'il existait aussi une
réserve ministérielle
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer un
peu plus précisément se vend quoi cette
réserve consisté quel est votre
proposition précise très simple mais
c'est à l'intérieur distribué 26
millions dans la plus totale opacité la
dotation d'action parlementaire ici au
sénat les publier elle est contrôlée et
bien si drogba nous réformons la
dotation d'action parlementaire au sénat
et suivant une méthode d'ailleurs que
nous avons mis en place pour la dotation
institutionnels c'est à dire avec un
collège des vice présidents je souhaite
que la même transparence puisque le mot
est à la mode pour créer la confiance
soit faite sur ce qui est donné
j'ai cité les 26 millions du ministère
de l'intérieur distribuer à des
collectivités locales dans la plus
totale opacité la région renvoie les
téléspectateurs à publicsenat.fr avec
une enquête très détaillé sur cette
réserve ministérielle la réserve
parlementaire avec tous les sur le site
du sénat aussi sur le sahara une petite
question
vous n'êtes pas contre le principe d'une
augmentation de la csg si c'est pour
alléger la charge sur les salaires d'une
d'un mot personnellement je ne suis pas
favorable dans la manière dont la cg
nous est proposée doit tellement elle
pèsera y compris sur des revenus
modestes je n'y suis pas favorable à
corps merci beaucoup merci jean francis
dernière partie de l'épreuve de vérité
maintenant avec nadège peljak de l'
agence france presse qui nous rejoint
pour parler politique
heller
l'épreuve de vérité avec les managers
vont s'enrichir vont soirée jeunes ont
alors tout simplement si je vous
demandais mots pour qualifier l'état de
votre parti en ce moment vous dites quoi
alors un mot médicale oh comme vous
voulez il sera en crise il en crise bien
sûr mais il ne nous lie ficultés qu'un
homme ou une femme d'esprit ne puisse se
transformer en succès an sur six ans sur
sa partie non je pense que nous avons un
travail d' analyses pour établir les
diagnostics pourquoi nous en sommes là
pourquoi nous avons échoué
tout au long de ces années et notamment
de cette dernière année que nous avons
les mains surtout de cette dernière
année parce que les autres années ça
c'était pas si mal passé que ça après
tout william hurt et les législatives
partielles vous avez leur combat les
menus le river n'aviez pas de batterie
et puis là il a reconnu une crise de
gouvernance
nous avons connu des questions des
interrogations sur le financement de
campagnes politiques
et puis c'est pas la mort présidentielle
sur le fonctionnement du parti
tous ces sujets là nous les avons
traités mais en même temps elles ont
suscité des interrogations légitimes
chez nos concitoyens
je crois que nous devons aussi nous
reposer la question depuis 2002 nous
étions rassemblés les radicaux des
républicains indépendants les gaullistes
des chrétiens démocrates
qu'est-ce qui est notre lien aujourd'hui
pour être ensemble si vous avez vision
de la société
quelle solidarité quelle illusion de la
communauté nationale
quelle place de la france comment nous
voyons l'europe mais les jus la relance
mais oui mais c'est ça ce qui forge le
coeur d'un mouvement politique
alors françois baroin dit on s'occupera
du parti après les législatives à leur
aisance
il est bien sûr qui a bien sûr c'est pas
à moi de le dire vous c'est vous qui le
dites mais ce que je veux dire c'est et
ça va tourner au pugilat ça tourne au
règlement de comptes
je ferai tout pour qu'il y ait un vrai
débat et que
vrai débat se limite pas un combat de
boxe parce que hier on avait
l'impression qu'ils avaient un petit peu
un combat de boxe bureau politique vous
étiez aux murs en planches n'était pas
lieu alors d'après ce qu'on nous a dit
j'ai quand même plusieurs sources assez
sûr qu'ils nous ont le problème expliqué
et que ça avait bombardé si j'ose
m'exprimer ainsi
pour monsieur raffarin qui s'est même
levé prêt à partir finalement il s'est
rassis tout le monde s'est calmé
enfin alors en gros un j'explique qu'en
vitesse la situation monsieur raffarin
dit elle mais les trois qui sont au
gouvernement les produits chimiques qui
son gouvernement
voilà ils ont pas ils ont pas légal
depuis qu'ils sont partis là ils sont
toujours des nôtres
et puis toute façon il faut passer les
désaccords enfin une autre tous les cas
il faut dire quand on est d'accord avec
monsieur macron ils ont dit écoute là
vraiment en gros tu joues trop et tu
joues contre ton camp alors est ce aussi
votre sentiment
écoutez on était au lendemain d'un choc
terrible pour 452 nos candidats parce
que ce choc c'est le résultat du premier
tour nous avions beaucoup de candidats
nouveaux jeunes et qui espérait pouvoir
être élu et rencontrer la conscience des
français
je crois que ce débat il va venir il va
venir en son temps quand la avant les
vacances soient prêts au débat apparu la
semaine prochaine aujourd'hui seul
objectif celui du sursaut que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure
celui de notre mobilisation qui dépasse
même la terre est partisan c'est
l'intérêt de la démocratie parlementaire
avec force et c'est vrai aussi pour la
gauche qu'il y ait des forces
d'opposition
est ce que vous les remettre à la
démocratie allait même si les deux
genres sont inégales même si les deux
genres sont illégales et bien de trouver
des équilibres nathalie kosciusko
morizet justement qui
en ballottage très difficile hier
monsieur raffarin est allé l'aider sur
le terrain vous allez vous aussi vous
sont les candidats les soutenir nathalie
kosciusko morizet je vais le faire
d'autres parce que on essaye de se
répartir et surf sur le terrain j'ai
soutenu si vous aviez lu un de vos
confrères aussi bien de te dis que cisco
morizet que d'autres et y compris et
thierry solère mais j'ai été dans
l'aisne me battre contre le front
national
malheureusement du côté des garçons avec
un succès pas encore totale parce que
pour moi c'était la priorité dans un
département qui avait donné la majorité
à marine le pen et qui se tiendrait vous
pour prendre parti dirige et c'était là
on le parti n'aura le moment venu un
congrès il aura le moment de l'élection
convenable des mines avant autour de
quel projet comment est venue notre
vivre ensemble
qu'est ce que nous allons proposer aux
français mon sujet c'est pas de choisir
tel ou tel mais ça les mobilisations
quand même des lignes la promesse de
2002 on est capable de la renouveler
fin 2010 est de 1000 2018 en refondant
une formation politique qui ait fait
d'hommes et de femmes aux projets
parfois un peu différent mais justement
alors michel vous demander pour qui et
qui allez-vous soutenir lors tout le
monde le sait ça secret de polichinelle
en gros il y aura deux candidats il
n'aura peut-être plus mais une heure au
moins deux je crois quand même bien
renseignés sur la question il y aura
laurent wauquiez qui a su chi chi qui
représente une droite on va dire qu'ils
s'assument
on va dire et puis monsieur xavier
bertrand une droite plus plus central
bon en fait deux lignes composées c'est
le côté non j'adore en permanence mais
c'est vous vous faites vous trouvez tier
2 je crois qu'il faut qu'on retrouve et
que les français ce qu'une droite
notamment une droite attentif à la
diversité une droite qui parle au peuple
français
c'est ça qu'il faut réinventer on n'est
pas dans une construction et français
attendent de nous qu'est ce que vous
proposez au pays
comment voulez vous contribuez dans les
cinq ans qui vient à sortir le pays du
désarroi dans lequel il est c'est aussi
un sujet qui est un médium et quelles
alternatives vous proposerez à la france
c'est sache alors vous défendez la
diversité de votre famille politique
donc son unité et pourtant c'est pas
forcément ce qui place passé selon
gérard longuet pour lui l'implosion est
une option on l'écouté vous réagissez
forcément un débat et qui n'écarte pas
l'implosion je suis complètement s'il
n'écarte pas un kiss in est prévu qu'il
se battrait pas parce que le higgs à
l'origine en 2002 lorsque l'ump était
créé gêné qui a généré ensuite
aujourd'hui les républicains il y avait
l'idée de constituer une force
suffisante pour accéder au deuxième plus
haut manifestement cette unité ne permet
plus d'accéder aux désirs geek ça ne
marche pas sur le plan électoral de il y
avait aussi le refus des populismes qui
était dans notre pacte fondateur ne
l'oublions pas ça veut dire que si nous
sommes de la droite et du centre
pour autant nous sommes très attachés à
un certain nombre de valeurs de la
république à des valeurs humaines à des
valeurs de société en partage et donc
c'est autour de ça que nous devons
refonder notre mouvement politique mais
vous ne répondez pas à notre question
parce que est ce que le parti va sonner
ou pas vous avez entendu monsieur lang a
dit oui on risque d'imploser on entend
partout tout à l'heure où paris vient
écouter sa musique indépendants vous
savez que c'est un nom qui circule pour
une nouvelle pas pour un nouveau parti
droit c'était un nom qui existait au sud
à 1 c'est plausible satirique ça a été
juste avant 2002 moi personnellement je
ferai tout pour un débat de qualité un
débat profondeur qu'ils soient pas
combat de boxe et pour reconstruire un
parti parce que je crois que nous avons
une responsabilité
l'implosion ça veut dire l'atomisation
l'atomisation ça veut dire la faiblesse
et on a 2 voir
d'être une opposition qui exerce sa
mission d'opposants pour notre formation
politique au parlement y compris ici au
sénat dans un groupe comme le groupe des
républicains
nous avons aussi un devoir de contrôler
gouvernement de faire des propositions
de s'opposer quand nous considérons
qu'il est important utile pour le pays
de s'opposer mais nous sommes là aussi
pour contribuer à redresser la france
vous espère bien sûr le la réussite des
mails magron jeu il sait la réussite du
président de la république c'est la
réussite de la france qui m'intéresse
toujours d'ex privilégier mon pays à mon
parti tout en étant très fidèle à la
formation politique gaulliste dans
lequel j'ai cheminé enfin qui envie de
dire que la france échoue diack madame
le pen qui se nourrit de désarroi et de
la misère dernière caisse blanche ont un
peu injustement vous parliez de emmanuel
macron honte à dire qu'il a quand même
brouillé les cartes eye-fi entre les
gens de droite dans son gouvernement
iad et il soutient des gens qui sont
chez vous il ya des gens chez vous qui
soutiennent qu'ils aient soutiennent la
politique alors sur quelle idée votre
parti peut faire la différence
je crois que c'est sur l'idée aussi de
la liberté de la responsabilité sur
l'idée de la place de la communauté
nationale de la manière dont guy
imaginons notre pays dans une identité
qui n'est pas repliée mais dans une
identité affirmée sur des sujets aussi
auquel je tiens beaucoup des sujets
territoriaux est ce que la france je le
disais tout à l'heure c'est uniquement
quelques rues métropole et quelques
régions puissante une france qui soit
tout à la fois pour le gaulliste que je
suis ça fait partie des idées
essentielles dans un pays qui va pas
bien a encore une question au président
du sénat puisque nous sommes à la veille
de la comparution à ce sera devant le
tribunal correctionnel de paris du mot
log michel aubier pour témoignages
mensongers sous serment
est-ce qu'il avait ni
et ses liens avec certains industriels
le groupe total notamment et en
minimisant par ailleurs l'impact de la
pollution est ce que ce que vous
attendez de ce procès qu'on respecte
parlement et notamment quand on prête
serment devant une commission denquête
du parlement considérer que c'est une
chose sérieuse un moment on veut
redonner confiance en la vie publique
on veut redonner confiance dans la vie
politique le parlement est un élément de
la vie démocratique
le respecter et essentiel laissons faire
la justice
c'est vrai que nous nous sommes portés
parties civiles
c'est vrai que je serai représenté à
l'audience par le président de la
commission denquête de l'époque
jean-françois husson est naturellement
par un avocat qui défendra les intérêts
hanks américiane en condamnation on
intervenait prison et la justice
je vous laisse ce mot justice décidera
nous avons voulu le bureau à l'unanimité
toutes sensibilités politiques rappelé
que le parlement d'une chose sérieuse
témoigner devant une commission denquête
du parlement est une chose très sérieuse
et le tribunal tranchera devra le
rappeler on va je comprends je traduis
un peu vos propos merci monsieur larcher
merci beaucoup merci de m'avoir invité
merci à tous bon soir à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]